he wrote about the most essential things
for throughout his life his quarrel was
with tyranny but also about everyday
things cartoons and cartoonists daylight
savings time ocean liners Moses the Boy
Scouts
he wondered are there men on the moon or
what he might do if he lived his life
again he travelled to America and wrote
about the land of corn and lobsters and
as somebody reminded me all the ice we
put in our water and the Civil War he
often called such articles his pop
boilers and so they were but possessed
of soaring rhetoric and entertaining
musings and his work goes on with
continuous posthumous publication
notably his complete speeches eight
volumes 9,000 pages his collected works
38 volumes 19,000 pages and hills dales
18 volumes of Churchill documents within
the official biography series 10 million
words and still counting four there five
more to come at least five more almost
uniquely Winston Churchill was a
statesman writer not only the sole
person to hold a high office in the two
greatest cataclysms of the past century
but the only one to write deeply about
them with a certain understandable
personal blast he always seemed to find
the right words and it's not too much to
suggest that Britain survived in 1940
because it was led by a professional
writer at a time when there was little
else to fight with Churchill mobilized
the English language as ed Murrow said
and sent it into battle what he did not
originate came from his knowledge of the
classics from the Bible to Shakespeare
and scores of great writers as a young
officer in India he read the classic
books just the students do a Hillsdale
storing them in his capacious memory
broadcasting in April 1941 just after
the US Congress had passed the
lend-lease act
he quoted a 19th century poet and not by
Eastern windows-only when daylight comes
comes in the light in front the Sun
climbs slow how slowly but westward look
the land is bright those lines are from
say not the struggle not available Hugh
Clough today funded by some candidate
for president they would be unknowable
however applicable except perhaps here
and at a few other places but the four
teams were another age bernard darwin
editor of the oxford dictionary of
quotations said Churchill didn't have to
identify Clough
as its source because in that more
literate age every English school child
knew it hearing those lines we were if
possible more sure than ever Darwin said
that mr. Churchill was the man for our
money and to quote professor David dukes
if you will allow that remark in
parentheses ladies and gentlemen do you
not sometimes long for someone at the
summit of our public life who can think
and write at that level writing and
statesmanship went hand in hand for
writing complimented Churchill's
political aims this is not history he
said of his war memoirs this is my case
he knew how influential his words would
be however it will be found much better
by all parties to leave the past to
history he said in 1948
especially as I propose to write that
history myself his writing had a
financial side the salaries of members
of parliament were low to this day they
have cramped offices few aides or
interns though born to an American
society Beauty and the son of a Duke
Churchill inherited no family wealth he
would later say I kept my family by my
pen and I lived from mouth to hand his
pen was kept busy because he had
expensive tastes his friend Fe Smith
Lord Birkenhead said Winston's tastes
are simple
he's always quite prepared to put up
with the best of everything the best
included silk underwear I have a very
sensitive cuticle he told his shocked
wife when she got the bills mr. Garr
bill running up to 200 a week in today's
money and though his drinking was vastly
exaggerated mostly by himself vintage
champagne and brandy
Chartwell his beloved home in Kent was a
money pit with a farm almost always in
the red he told his colleague David
Lloyd George I'm going to make it pay
whatever it costs he was a born writer
Herald historian found a dramatic
article he wrote in 1889
age 15 about an imagined invasion of
Russia a remarkably accurate forecast of
what actually happened twenty-five years
later young Winston even set the date
1914 the Year World War one would break
upon Europe I proposed to tell you
something some but not all about his
writing it would take a semester all his
books are still readily available indeed
nowadays more available than ever for a
Rosetta books as published most of his
works as ebooks as they did with
Hillsdale Churchill biography so let us
look at some of his most characteristic
books to give you an idea the depth of
his imagination his scholarship is
wonderfully entertaining writing and
it's a timeless relevance to our time in
my early life is autobiography of his
first 30 years is the book everyone
should read first it is now established
that Churchill took liberties in it for
example he was not so nearly ignored and
abandoned by his parents as he implies
his nephew Peregrine showed me Lady
Randolph Diaries showing us he spent a
remarkable amount of time
with Winston and his brother Jack before
they left for school Winston was a very
naughty boy
Peregrin said and his parents were much
concerned about it my early life is a
wonderful treat one reviewer likened it
to a beaker of champagne for its style
and taste its sense of adventure and
self-deprecating humor its ability to
let the reader peer over our authors
shoulder as events on fault
of course as we Manchester wrote
church's youth was virtually
incomprehensible than most people then
alive he had been born into the English
aristocracy at a time when British
nobleman who are considered and
certainly considered themselves a little
less than godlike master 1/4 of the
Earth's surface and population thrice
the size of the Roman Empire at full
flush they controlled Great Britain
herself to an extent that would be
inconceivable in any civilized nation
today 1% of the country's population
33,000 people own two-thirds of the
wealth and that wealth before two world
wars devoured it was breathtaking my
early life records that time and his
adventures in it with words which will
live as long as any 20th century author
is read to examples demonstrate my one
is Churchill's recollection of his
examination in mathematics which is my
favorite because I had similar
experience we were arrived in an Alice
in Wonderland world of the portals of
which the a quadratic equation this with
a strange grimace pointed the way to the
theory of indices which again handed on
the intruder to the full rigors of the
binomial theorem further dim chambers
lighted by solid and sulfurous fires
were reputed to contain a dragon called
the differential calculus
but this monster was beyond the bounds
appointed by the civil service
commissioners who regulated this stage
of pilgrims heavy journey we turned
aside not indeed to the uplands of the
delectable mountains but into a strange
car door are things like anagrams and
acoustics called sines cosines and
tangents apparently they were very
important especially when multiplied by
each other or by themselves there was a
question in my third and last exam about
these cosines and tangent in a highly
Square rooted condition which must have
been decisive upon the whole of my
afterlife luckily I had seen its ugly
face only a few days before and
recognized that at first sight I've
never met any of these creatures since
my second air except excerpt occurs his
church who passes out of the Royal
Military Academy and into the world and
it's about horses and let me qualify
that it's a bit grading on modern ears
because he spoke of sons not daughter
let us not be generational chauvinist as
William Manchester said church it was a
Victorian but he did learn he came
around to women's suffrage for example
observing the role the heroic role women
had played in World War one and as his
daughter told me when he realized how
many women would vote for him
and he did capture the women's vote in
every election after that so here it is
here I say to parents especially wealthy
parents don't give you some money as far
as you can afford to give him horses no
hour of life is lost that is spent in
the saddle young men have often been
ruined through owning horses or through
backing horses did I skip a thing let's
see yeah there he is or through backing
horses but never through riding them
unless of course they break their necks
which taken at a gallop is a very good
death to die with the help of his mother
and other influential friends our author
won early assignments as a war reporter
he'd written five books by age 25 for
them based on his experiences in Queen
Victoria's little Wars his grandest
early work which hills dales Paul Rey
compares to that of Thucydides is the
river war published 115 years ago but
soon we hope to be reissued in a
masterful new annotated edition by
Professor James Muller watch for it on
our website you won't want to miss it
the river war is Churchill's brilliant
history of British involvement in Muslim
tribal wars it remains insightful to our
own time combined with stirring personal
adventures these are passages of deep
reflection of how enlightened democratic
governments deal with primitive or
religious tyranny remarkably professor
ray said this 20 years ago at the Wilson
Center at a conference I was at quote in
an age when we are likely to be called
on to respond to ugly little conflicts
marked by social sectarian and tribal
rivalries in odd corners of the world
the Arabian Peninsula the Caucasus the
Horn of Africa the Balkans Central
Africa the Maghreb I can think of no
historical work that better deserves our
attention unquote far from accepting
uncritically the superiority of European
civilization the river war appreciates
the longing for freedom among the in
soudanese but he fought church' finds
their regime defective in it's
inadequate protections of human liberty
in 1885 the Sudan had been overrun by
dervish tribesmen under their religious
leader Lamacq T culminating in the
assassination of the British envoy
general Gordon at the capital of
Khartoum 14 years later London sent
general Kitchener and a combined British
Egyptian force including Churchill to
reestablish anglo-egyptian sovereignty
notwithstanding British Egyptian
weaponry and valour the obstacles
presented by the Nile the desert the
climate cholera and a brave fanatical
enemy were formidable Church oh of
course
celebrates kitcheners victory but he
doesn't hesitate to criticize the
barbaric actions of his army the
desecration of the Mahdi's tomb the
disdain for the fallen foe after the
Battle of Omdurman my favorite passage
from the original his Churchill's visit
to the battlefield 3 days after British
artillery had done its terrible work and
consider how strange this must have
sounded to Victorians
at the zenith of the British Empire if
you want to know what war can be even
today with precision guided drones and
smart bombs you have only to read this
description quote the site was appalling
the smell redoubled the horror
I've tried to guild war and to solace
myself for the loss of dear and gallant
friends with the thought that the
soldier's death for a cause that he
believes in will count for much whatever
may be beyond this world but there was
nothing dual K at the courtroom about
the dervish dead
nothing of the dignity of unconquerable
manhood all was filthy corruption
Churchill asserts his characteristic
magnanimity as he and a companion
stopped to give a comfort to the
helpless dying enemy a few days after
the battle many an english reader was
shocked when Churchill declared these
words brave men has ever walked the
earth
the conviction was born in on me that
their claim beyond the grave in respect
of a valiant death was not less good
than that which any of our countrymen
can make he adds a note of fatalism
there and however only anticipates that
of the victors for time which lasted
sciences science laughs at valor will in
due course - contemptuously brush both
combatants away
the world crisis in 1923 through 31
church republished the world crisis is
memoir of world war 1 when he began as
First Lord of the Admiralty fell
disastrously from power commanded a
battalion in Flanders returned to the
government as minister of munitions and
attended the Versailles peace conference
as to recommend the big book by
Churchill Iost sight the world crisis
like all his war books is highly
personal one of his friends called
Winston's brilliant autobiography
disguised as a history of the universe
and one of his enemy said Winston has
written an enormous book all about
himself and he calls it the world crisis
even if you don't read war books you'll
be absorbed by Churchill's account of
the awful unfolding events the
international rivalries that caused the
Great War his failed effort to break the
deadlock in Europe by forcing the
Dardanelles
knocking Turkey out of the war and
aiding the Russians the carnage on the
western front how Germany almost won and
then lost the war in 1918 one of his
critics Robert Rhodes James regarded the
world crisis as Churchill's masterpiece
noting that one can never quite separate
search of the orator from search of the
writer his fourth volume the aftermath
chronicles the ten years after victory
including the Versailles settlement the
Irish treaty the Cairo conference in
1921 which settled the boundaries that
we live with in the Middle East today
Churchill pushed hard at Cairo for a
Kurdish homeland to protect the Kurds as
he said against some future bully in
Iraq the Foreign Office overruled it
saying that of course Iraq would never
be a problem to the west my first
excerpt from the world crisis is the
favor to General Colin Powell who asked
me for the attribution Churchill's
admonition never to go to war unless
you're interested directly involved or
you have overwhelming superiority advice
always worth pondering in 1911
cars are wilhelm sent a gunboat to
Agadir French Morocco and France almost
went to war with Germany over it
Churchill was describing the exchange of
telegrams that few Ballou between Berlin
Paris and London as the Agadir crisis
deepened can I have my napkin please
apologize for my cold they sound very
cautious and correct these deadly words
soft quiet voices purring courteous
grave exactly measured phrases and large
peaceful rooms but with less warning
canons had opened fire and nations had
been struck down by the same Germany so
now the admiralty wireless whispers
through the ether to the tall masts of
ships and captains paced their decks
absorbed and thought it is nothing it is
less than nothing it is too foolish to
fantastic to be thought of in the
twentieth century no one would do such
things civilization has climbed above
such perils the interdependence of
Nations in trade and traffic the sense
of public law the Hague Convention
liberal principles the Labour Party high
finance Christian charity common sense
and rendered such nightmares impossible
are you quite sure it would be a pity to
be wrong such a mistake can only be made
once once for all
of course the mistakes were made the
world plunged in the war three years
later in Churchill mobilized the Navy I
mean here he describes the faithful
cabinet meetings meeting of July 24th
1914 a month after a Serbian nationalist
had murdered the arch' to the Archduke
Francis Ferdinand of Austria the cabinet
on Friday afternoon that sat long
revolving the Irish problem the
discussion turned principally upon the
boundaries of Fermanagh and Tyrone upon
the disposition of these clusters of
humble parishes turned at that moment
the political future of Great Britain
turning this way and that in search of
an exit from the deadlock the cabinet
toiled around the muddy byways of
Fermanagh and Tehran the discussion had
reached its inconclusive end and the
cabinet was about to separate when the
quiet grave tones of Sir Edward Grey's
voice were heard reading a document
which has just been brought to him from
the Foreign Office
it was the Austrian note to Serbia he'd
been reading or speaking for several
minutes before I could disengage my mind
from the tedious and bewildering debate
which had just been closed this note was
clearly an ultimatum such as had never
been penned in modern times it seemed
absolutely impossible that any state in
the world could accept it more than any
acceptance however abject would satisfy
the aggressor the parishes of Fermanagh
and Tyrone faded back into the mists and
squalls of Ireland and a strange light
began immediately but by perceptible
gradations to fall and grow upon the map
of Europe with this great capacity for
recall Churchill harked back to that
exact moment eight years later in 1922
and he was introducing the Irish Free
State bill to Parliament the Irish
quarrel he said had been interrupted by
the Great War every institution almost
in the world was strained great empires
have been overturned the whole map of
Europe has been changed the position of
count of countries has been violently
all through the modes and thought of men
the whole outlook on affairs the
grouping of parties all had encountered
violent and tremendous changes in the
deluge which has struck the world but as
the de Livy subsides and the waters fall
short we see the dreary steeples affirm
Anna and Tyrone emerging once again the
integrity of their quarrel is one of the
few institutions that has been unaltered
in the Cataclysm which has swept the
world a few years later he reflected on
those times the Lord Beaverbrook
unteachable from infancy to tomb there
is the first and main characteristic
mankind and Churchill sadly shook his
head perhaps we should - from early 1929
when the Conservatives lost the general
election to late 1939 when he returned
his head of the Admiralty Churchill was
in the political wilderness isolated by
his opposition to the India bill and his
demands that Britain rearm in the face
of Hitler he was not a politician who
takes the public pulse and engages in
popularity contests he never has
hesitated to tell people things they
didn't want to hear and until his
warnings were proved all too real he
took the heat for unpopular views yet
this decade was no wilderness for church
of the writer I lived mainly at
Chartwell he recalled where I had much
to amuse me always in need of money he
worked late into the night laboring on
hundreds of articles and some of his
most compelling books including his
great biography the life of his ancestor
John Churchill 1st Duke of Marlborough
no less a scholar than Leo Strauss
called Mara the greatest historical work
written in our century an inexhaustible
mine of political wisdom and
understanding which should be required
reading for every student of political
science I'm reading it right now on
Kindle amazing some of our presidential
candidates should read it it provides
very good advice about getting out of
tight spots Maurice Ashley church's
leading assistant on Marlborough wrote
that his boss held courage and honor as
leading virtues which could at times
eclipse other considerations that is
Churchill's main weakness as a
historical writer he said history had
first been a pleasant method of making
money and in the end it was a means of
self justification but Ashley continues
there is no doubt whatever the church
who possessed a powerful sense of
history as Isaiah Berlin has written
Churchill's central organizing principle
was an historical imagination so strong
so comprehensive as to encase the whole
of the future in a framework of a rich
and multicolored past
a piece which summarizes their view is
Churchill's 1930 article if Lee had not
won the Battle of Gettysburg as if
seated around a dinner table sure she
reminds us of course that everyone knows
Lee occupied little roundup and time to
forestall a flanking movement by the
Union left and Confederate guns clear
the field on the fatal day Pickett's
Charge smashes the federal line and
general Meade falls back into Maryland
Lincoln and his government seeing ruin
approach fleet in New York the Army of
Northern Virginia occupies Washington
and the world's only superpower Great
Britain recognizes the Confederacy then
Lee in his hour of victory supplants
Jefferson Davis as the moral leader of
the southern nation in Church of Rights
if Lee had been merely a soldier his
achievements would have ended on the
battlefield it was his August
declaration that the victorious
Confederacy would pursue no policy
toward the slaves which was not in
harmony with the moral conceptions of
Western Europe that opened the high
roads along which we are now marching so
prosperous Lee this was in 1930 so
leaves he frees the slaves we all knew
that he hated slavery Lincoln then
declares that the moral issue separating
the states no longer exists and at the
Treaty of Harpers Ferry in September
1863 the United States recognizes that
the south is independent and the slaves
of free the USA and the CSA live
uneasily side by side both on to the
teeth through 1914 when war threatens
Europe they then joined with Great
Britain to form the english-speaking
Association which combined whose
combined power and influence is so great
that it forced all's war the ESA for
force sorry forces the general
disarmament and the establishment of
constitutional monarchies in Russia
Germany and austria-hungary but notice
how this tale melts together Churchill's
deeply held beliefs anglo-american unity
peace through strength sovereigns who
reigned but don't rule Churchill then
suggest what might have happened if Lee
had lost the defeated South he says
would have smoldered in resentment
enacting laws to compromise the rights
of freedmen armies of carpetbaggers
might have descended to take advantage
of them America though United might have
developed a national psyche unwilling to
involve herself in European quarrels a
war in 1914 would almost certainly have
meant the ruin of Russia and Germany
perhaps even Bolshevik and fascist
takeovers Churchill concludes his
imagine present 1930 whether the emperor
wilhelm ii will be successful in
carrying the project of European unity
forward by another important stage at
the forthcoming pan European conference
in Berlin is still a matter of prophecy
but let him not forget that he might
well have found himself eating the
bitter bread of exile the dethroned
sovereign and a broken man loaded with
unutterable reproach and this we repeat
might well have been his fate if Lee had
not won the Battle of Gettysburg so
think of it the European Union in 1930
know Lenin know Hitler know Mussolini
truly Winston Churchill was a graduate
optimist in the last few years of his
life Church of gave in to the pessimism
he had always dodged before and despite
reports he was never much bothered by
depression until very old age we
secretary private secretary Anthony
Montagu Brown Alphin dined with him
alone trying to keep his spirits up by
reminding him of all the heat
accomplished
yes Churchill would say I have worked
very hard and accomplished a great many
things only to accomplish nothing in the
end I speculated an Anthony agreed that
Sir Winston referred to his failure to
cement the special relationship with
America which wavered after the Suez
Crisis and never developed as he wished
and to reach what he called a final
settlement with the Soviets although in
1949 he predicted that communism would
one day expire in the blink of an eye he
also was saddened Anthony added that his
father had not lived to see what he had
accomplished at dinner one evening in
1946 his daughter Sarah pointed to an
empty chair if you had the power to put
someone in that chair whom would you
choose she expecting them to say Caesar
and Napoleon marlborough but he quickly
replied all my father of course
Churchill then went on to write what he
called private article never published
in his lifetime about a winter night in
his studio where he's attempting to copy
a portrait of his father he's just
giving a twirl to the mustache when he
feels an odd sensation and they are
sitting in his red leather armchair is
Lord Randolph Churchill with flashing
blue eyes and a cigarette holder poised
just as Winston remembered him in his
prime what are you doing Winston his
father says Winston explains he's
painting I only do it as a hobby yes I'm
sure you never could earn your living
that way
father observes how do you get your
living Winston replies I write books and
articles for the press unimpressed Lord
Randolph asked what year it is 1947
Winston says so more than fifty years
have passed as his father a lot must
have happened tell me about it so
Winston age 73 recites to his forty year
old father everything that has happened
since Lord Randolph died in 1895 without
ever revealing and this is the great
irony and charm of the piece the rolls
Winston himself played the shocks is
followed by informing him that women
have the vote the Socialists are in
power Burma is independent in India has
gone down the drain his father groans
what about Ireland did they get home
rule the South got it but Ulster stayed
with us on the south and Republic
no one knows what they are for Faust
they are neither in nor out of the
Empire
Winston mentions that there have been
Wars Lord Randolph looks up with a start
war did you say yes indeed before we've
had nothing else but war since democracy
took charge did we win
yes we want all our Wars all our enemies
were beaten down but Wars like these
must have cost a million lives upon each
of them about 30 million men were killed
in battle in the last one seven million
were murdered in cold blood mainly by
the Germans they made human slaughter
pens like the Chicago stockyards Europe
is a ruin ten capitals in Eastern Europe
are in Russian hands they are communists
now you know Karl Marx and all that it
may well be then the even worst war is
drawing near far gone are the days of
Queen Victoria and a settled world order
Lord Randolph is stunned Winston he says
you told me a terrible tale I would have
never believed such things could happen
I'm glad I did not live to see them as I
listened to you unfolding these fearful
facts you seem to know a great deal
about them I never expected you would
develop so far and so fully of course
you are too old now to think about such
things but when I hear you talk I really
wonder you didn't go into politics you
might have made done a bit to help you
might even have made a name for yourself
his father strikes a match to light a
cigarette there's a tiny flash and he
vanishes and the chair is empty and
Winston writes I rub my brush again in
my paint and turned to finish the
moustache but so vivid had my fancy
being that I felt too tired to go on
also my cigar had gone out and the ash
had fallen among the paints thank you
four questions raise your hand and we
stand
you saw it all oh yeah
hi Randy
he predicted cellphones 50 years hence
he wrote it not one was at 1932-33 he
predicted an age of mass communication
and greatly feared it 24/7 news media
that knows everything and nothing all at
the same time instant reporting of news
stuff we hear when we turn on the
television every night he also said that
in 50 years we will be able to grow only
the parts of the chicken such as we had
for lunch we have to worry about the
legs of the tail just the bits we need
so some of it was a little far out but
some of it was very very much on the
mark and he greatly feared that advent
of mass media the an age when you don't
have time to contemplate what you're
going to say and before you say you'd
better be advised by a dozen different
pollsters to tell you what what not to
say or what you know or what would not
go well down in the Iowa primary yes
yeah of course he yeah he he regretted
it very much he said Harvard speaking at
Harvard in 1943 said man has parted
company with his faithful friend the
horse and the sailed forth on the azure
and the wings of eagles Eagles being
represented by the infernal but I mean
the internal combustion engine even
elderly parliamentarians like myself
were forced to acquire a high degree of
mobility yeah but that was his fear in
the 30s and the the SI fifty years hence
is in thoughts and adventures which is a
fine addition of which is out by the is
I press you can get it from Amazon
edited by Jim Mahler with lots of good
footnotes and it's worth reading along
with all the other essays and their
including the one on Hitler by the way
which Jim doesn't think belongs there
because itself out of touch with great
men you know Churchill said that when
asked to compare in Napoleon with it
like he said I refuse to disparage to
the dead and repugnant to me to compare
the great emperor of the French with a
squalid caucus Boston butcher and your
questions
I'm not a professor well we have a
section on our website called truths and
heresies the Church of Center has one
called leading Church of myths I wrote
lots of those we try to refer people to
it all the time we write stiphu letters
to Forbes when they say silly things
about the Dardanelles and Gallipoli most
people can't seem to distinguish between
the two there were two separate
operations Lord Mountbatten who was in
charge of combined operations in
nineteen in the Second World War said
that if they had combined operations in
1915 they might have pulled that one off
the dog knows incorrectly of course they
didn't and they were very very much
disjointed in their approach the
military versus the Navy but those are
two things you can do the web gives you
an maximum access to everyone in the
world it's just a question of getting
them to find you you know yes
one over here someone do you mean the
fun they had on the way down
yes well the first thing Turman decided
to do was to offer the Prime Minister I
mean he was the leader of the Opposition
90 46 a glass of whiskey and so he
poured it and Truman spoke with a bright
sprightly brief staccato air and they
had gotten to the point where they were
calling each other Winston and Harry and
so he said well Winston what do you
think of the whiskey and Churchill
looked at him and said my dear mr. CREB
My dear Harry it's not whiskey it's very
good it's not whiskey it's bourbon and
the train stops in the middle of the
suburbs of Maryland while someone whose
son off to run to an all-night liquor
store and get a bottle of scotch and
then after dinner they decided to play
poker they said Winston have you ever
played poker yes he said I learned poker
in the Boer War and Clark Clifford who
was the president's assistant wrote
about this later in Reader's Digest and
I also interviewed him about it and he
said we thought the Boer War was
fantastic none of us ever knew when the
Boer War was fifty years before you know
so they decided to play poker now the
president's poker team his staff were
pretty cracked pork players and after a
few rounds it became obvious that
Winston wasn't up to their standard and
he'd lost a bundle of money about $200
so at that point he excused himself and
went to the tents and the president's
press secretary Charlie Ross they spoke
with less formality in those days said
to the president well boss what do you
think of his playing it's pretty grim in
it and Truman said well boys it's
obvious that the standards of poker in
Great Britain are not
to the standards here in the United
States and Charlie Ross said Boston you
want us to play poker do you want us to
carry this fellow and Truman said well
he is our guest we should treat him as a
guest and try to make him feel he hasn't
been a total disaster in this poke
around so for the rest of the trip Clark
Clifford said I saw guys drop out with
three aces full House's slushies and at
the end Church it was $50 a head and
thought thought he'd acquitted himself
very well on behalf of Great Britain
Truman of course also read the iron
curtain speech with sinews of peace
speech which he later denied having read
in advance on the way down and said he
thought it would go down very well and
it certainly did he went down like a
clanging bell and Churchill and Truman
were both greatly criticized for that
afterward but Truman was trying to
maintain plausible deniability you know
just like we do about emails
the Boer War in South Africa yes well of
course they only controlled part of
South Africa and then when the when the
the Boer War broke out it was the second
one that they they had two fights they
natal and orange River Colony and
Transvaal war Dutch natal and what was
the other province who knows someone
knows Cape Colony war British and what
happened was that the Boers who were in
the majority wanted to legislate the
whole country and that's when the war
broke out Churchill as usual was
tremendously magnanimous towards the
boys and went on a lecture tour in 1901
where he went all around the country
facing mainly hostile audience since we
weren't big on imperialist Britain and
he would he would show magic lantern
slides like we did with our magic
lantern here and at one point he shows
the slide of a more Horseman mounted on
his horse with his rifle and the
audience broke into cheers for the enemy
and Churchill said you are right to
applaud him he's one of the greatest
fighting men you'll ever see and then
after that in 1906 when he was
Undersecretary of State for the colonies
he helped arrange the Transvaal peace
the peace pact which led to the Union of
South Africa and he met Louie Bota who
later claimed that he captured him
personally but that wasn't true it's one
of both his lieutenants I think Bolton
led the column that captured Churchill
who was a war correspondent but they
became fast friends and Botta
was the guy who really he was the
Desmond Morton of 1914 telling Churchill
what the Germans were really up to and
that he in turn at that time was First
Lord of the Admiralty and he said he
should make sure that the Navy is ready
because you're coming into a
so his friendships there were very great
his greatest friend was young Christian
Smuts the great South African prime
minister who actually campaigned and
lost on ending apartheid in 1949 so he
was he fought for Britain but he
understood the Boers aspirations and
tried to accommodate them with the
Transvaal constitution an issue a
question